Alright guys, it's time to jump in to the core content.
It's time to get in, pick our city and niche and get going and get deals coming in and
close that first deal.
But I want to share really quick, this is how I want you to attack the content, okay?
I know I've been in other programs where they tell you, hey, watch the whole thing and then
come back and watch it again and do it.
I know I've been in other programs that just tell you all sorts of different things and
I'm not telling you that.
Here's what I want you to do.
I want you to watch a module, okay?
So we start with module one and then I want you to do the thing.
So module one talks about picking the city and picking the niche.
So you're going to watch that module and then you're going to pick the city and the niche.
And you're not going to go to module two until that's done, okay?
Then once you've picked the city and the niche because you've done the homework and the whole
deal, then you're going to go to module two and you're going to learn how to build a list.
And guess what?
You're going to build a list before you go to module three and you're not going to go
to module three until you build the list.
Because what I know is that in the times I have just gone and gone through all the content,
what happens is I listen to all this and I'm like, oh, cool, well, I'm just kind of like
passively soaking things in and I'm like, I get done, I'm like, oh my gosh, that's a
lot, that's a lot.
But if you take it in bites and you watch the first module and you don't allow yourself
to go to the next one until you've done the thing, done the actual action step, you have
a lot more, you go a lot quicker because you're just, you're tacking it in chunks, okay?
So I do want you to watch the module and then do it.
And then watch the next one and then do it.
Because then by the time we get to module seven, we are pitching the business owner,
okay?
And we're getting a deal.
That is my advice.
Another little piece, I've had people that have gone through all of this in one day.
My recommendation is to watch a module a day and consume this over a week's time or maybe
even a little bit longer.
It's up to you, but I've had students that have literally watched every module in one
day and I'm telling you right now, even though it's my own stuff, I would probably want to
blow my brains out and I probably wouldn't retain much by the end of the day.
So I think the very best way to do this is watch a module and do it and do one module
a day and do it well, okay?
So guys, let's freaking do this.
Let's jump into module one, watch it, and then do it.